This video uses three examples from the chicken
genome to illustrate common uses of clone
placement data:
- Find genomic clones that contain a gene
of interest
- Use clone placements to recognize a genomic
region with potential mis-assembly
- Use clone placements to recognize potential
structural variations
A companion video that focuses on clone FTP
content is linked at the end of this video.
Very briefly, clone placements are created
by aligning end and insert sequences on genome
assemblies annotated at NCBI.
To generate a clone placement for end sequences,
both ends (forward and reverse) must be placed
on the same assembly molecule.
For the first example,
let's find clone placements in the region
of the chicken WDR3 gene.
I'm starting in the Genome Data viewer, but
if you happened to be in a Gene record, you
could link from there to the same GDV display
we are about to see.
I'll select the previous chicken assembly,
Gallus-gallus 5.0, but that is simply because
our three examples better illustrate the utility
of clone placements in that assembly.
You might want to have a look at the wdr3
gene region in the updated assembly to see
how it has improved.
To get to the region of the WDR3 gene, use
the Search box on the left.
We now see the WDR3 gene model.
The next step is to add tracks for clone placements.
From the Tracks menu, mouse over NCBI Recommended
Track Sets then select Assembly Support.
This adds a pre-defined group of tracks, including
clone placements for the 3 libraries with
the largest number of placements.
Clones with unique concordant placements are
displayed as solid blue lines.
Unique discordant clones display as a solid
red line and multiple discordant clones display
as dotted red line.
This clone also has a grey background, indicating
that not all end sequences associated with
the clone support this placement.
If you wanted to, you could add other clone
placement tracks in the Genomic Clones set.
And notice that you can upload other data,
such as one of the GFF files on the Clone
FTP site.
Okay, we're now ready to identify good clones
for the WDR3 gene.
I'll adjust the zoom a bit in order to better
see the assembly gap.
I'll also add a marker for the gap region.
And I'll need to scroll down to see the clone
tracks.
Now you see that the CH261 library includes
several blue clones, those with unique concordant
placements, that contain this assembly gap,
so we've met our first goal of finding genomic
clones for a gene of interest.
Let's move on to the second example, a quick
look at using clone placements to assess the
quality of an assembly, in this case, to recognize
a genomic region with potential mis-assembly.
I've moved over to chicken chromosome Z.
And we see a dramatic change in placements
from unique concordant to discordant at about
72 megabases.
This change ocurrs in all 3 libraries, indicating
a likely mis-assembly in the region.
The DNA source for this Gallus_gallus-5.0
assembly is the same as in the CH261 library,
but different in the two other libraries,
further supporting a mis-assembly here.
In the final example, we look at clone placements
that indicate possible structural variation.
I've moved over to chromosome 21.
And here we see a few smaller regions in the
J_AC and J_AD libraries with placements of
both concordant and discordant clones.
This mixture is suggestive of structural variation,
but additional analyses are needed to verify
this, including close evaluation of boundaries
and sequencing of clones to narrow down locations.
Notice that the end clones from the CH261
library have only concordant placements in
these regions.
Remember that the source sequence for CH261
is different from the other two libraries,
leaving open the possibility of genomic variation
in these regions.
That concludes this tutorial.
Please use the Support Center link found on
most NCBI pages for your questions and feedback;
we would love to hear from you.